so for starters I'm gonna use my arm I'm
going to use my terrible Akron in and
out I yeah I I no one has yet come up
with a better at like a way that makes
the seed not look awkward there so
anyway I'm going to factorize first so
have a look at that numerator what can I
do what if I got cool that works for me
doesn't need to be done other
denominators that looks good
having a factorized I can use that to
work out the asymptotes and the
intercepts okay firstly the vertical
asymptotes I can see that there's going
to be if I draw my set of axes here
there's going to be a single vertical
asymptote what is it okay let's be a
little more specific it's a vertical
asymptote so it's actually x equals zero
so I'm gonna put that on and I'm also
going to label it so this is the y-axis
x equals zero got that guy no other
vertical asymptotes now like I said the
question gave you a clue it said hey
you've got a horizontal asymptote of one
but how could we tell that without them
give you us the clue because we can't
yeah very good you're looking at the top
of the bottom you compare them and
you're like they're growing up more or
less the same rate the minus X to the
minus two they shrink away into
insignificance next to the x squared so
therefore these are really going to the
same value okay so therefore y equals
one there is my horizontal asymptote
okay
worth pointing out that you know how we
said oh they are approaching the same
value right but which one will be bigger
when X is when X's are over here when X
is a positive value do you see that this
star bar will just be a little bit
smaller than this one right a tiny bit
so therefore you're going to have a
smaller numerator than the denominator
that's below one isn't it like say 99
over 100 is below 1 whereas if you turn
it upside down if you go negative right
what will happen ah
now interestingly in this case I think
we're going to get the same thing
because oh wait no yeah no yeah no you
were right because that double negative
in there means you go just above okay
because yes so you'll get like 199 or
something of that nature so I know I'm
going to approach this side from below
and this said from above I've got this
guy here okay
can we find out anything else well we've
got our asymptotes how do I work out my
intercepts there yep so when y equals 0
I'm finding X intercepts and I've read
that off the numerator so I can see
that's going to be yep so let's put
negative 1 here and 2 is over here and
the last thing I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
put some regions you okay so yeah yeah
correct
because vertical asymptotes the reason
why graphs can't cut vertical asymptotes
is because vertical asymptotes come from
discontinuities which by then very like
by the word discontinuity it means
you're not there the graph kind of
exists there um you can't put in x
equals 0 the graph the function just
explodes on the other hand horizontal or
oblique asymptotes they don't tell you
anything about what's happening in here
they only tell you about what's
happening in over at around here which
is why in the middle of the graph the
horizontal asymptote might as well not
exist so we can cross it okay which we
will come to in a second so I'm going to
do my regions now okay so X minus 2 X
plus 1 and I'll come to this one in a
second so here's what X minus 2 looks
like here's what X plus 1
looks like now x squared right I'm
actually not going to draw it in because
it's always positive or zero right so
therefore it's it never changes the sign
of the whole object right no matter what
value of x I put into here you're
dividing by a positive number but if you
have a number and divide it by something
positive it'll stay whatever sign it was
before positive data are positive it's
positive negative divided by positive
stays negative okay so I'm actually
going to ignore him I can do the rest of
this though let's have a look so on the
left here whoops are better on the left
here I've got two negative factors two
negatives gives me a positive like so
down here I've got a positive and a
negative so I'm going to go negative and
then over here it switches well this one
okay so these are the regions that are
going to go through okay
now lastly they didn't give us the clue
they said hey you're gotta cross the
horizontal asymptote this happens quite
a lot actually so how do I work out
where that happens well I let X equal
sorry I let y equal the horizontal
asymptote y equals one so if that's the
case I'm going to go one equals x
squared minus X minus 2 on x squared
yeah and this is very easy to solve what
will I do to both sides yep so I
multiply it across I've got an x squared
on both sides Bam Bam now what yeah I'm
gonna add X to both sides so there's
negative one I've got to keep my scale
on the horizontal axis I've got to keep
it consistent so there's negative two so
there is where I cross okay so I've got
an intercept there and intercept there a
crossing there do you remember that we
said we were going to approach this
asymptote the horizontal one from
beneath well that makes sense doesn't it
look I can I can see how it's going to
happen there so in fact I'm just going
to draw that in all right so it's really
easy it goes from positive down to
negative and it it's obeying all these
asymptotes over here you can see well
I'm gonna have to go down two
join these two points that I know it had
go toward this acetone but I have to
come back toward the horizontal
asymptote so that's why it approaches
from the top on this side okay so I'm
gonna do this like so okay
now ordinarily before this topic I would
stop at this point okay but because now
I know calculus I can actually go a
little bit further because there is a
stationary point on this graph and I can
locate its position how do I do that
alright let's differentiate so dy/dx as
we were putting out before I'm going to
avoid differentiating as much as I can
because it's a quotient which requires
the quotient rule what I have to do it
at least once to find this stationary
point so let's do it
Vee is x squared u - will be 2x - 1 - u
x squared - x - 2 times V - which is 2x
okay all divided through by X to the 4
yep ok now this looks like a big garbled
mess but I'm crossing my fingers really
hard I hoping it's going to work out so
that's going to give me 2x cubed minus x
squared watch out for your side here I'm
not even going to touch it I'm going to
do the expansion first you're going to
get 2x cubed that's convenient
- 2x squared - 4 X okay so I can see
kids all canceled oh sorry
ok I have a denominator that's an easy
thing to forget I have minus x squared
plus 2x squared so how many X Squared's
are there minus 1 plus 2 it's just a
single x squared - -4 X that's + 4 X
like so
ok now this is interesting
I can factorize this why did you know to
factorize you're right why did we know
how to do that
it looks like a mess I know to factorize
because you're looking for when this is
zero right so I'm going to take out a
factor of X which leaves you a 2 X plus
4
like so now it looks like x equals 0
would make the 0 but it doesn't do you
see why because actually it's it's a
discontinuity so you only have a
solution x equals negative 4
do you see that now if I didn't know
anything about this graph I would have
to go further I'd have to use a second
derivative or the first derivative table
of values in order to work out what on
earth is going on here but I don't need
to do that do I
I already know what kind of stationary
point this is buy it like it can't be a
minimum all right so I know where it is
as well there's minus 1 minus 2 minus 3
minus 4 so I need to move this over a
little bit that's where it turns right
there ok and now that I have calculus
I'd be expected to also find the
coordinates minus 4 comma we can work
this one out 16 plus 4 is 20 minus 2 is
18 divided by 16 which is 9 9 8
tada